so watch the moment a 24-year old former
sanitation worker finds out he was
accepted into one of the top law schools
in the world or unclicking rayon statin
is going to Harvard Law School guys his
story is one of grace under pressure and
perseverance he was raised by single dad
who worked endless hours to pay food to
pay bills and to provide food and
because of that statin struggled in
school one teacher even told him he
needed to be in special education
classes well guess what as his home life
improved he ended up acing that class
after high school he attended the
University of Maryland and he gave the
commencement speech in 2018 he told me
his co-workers encouraged him to follow
his dream it was the people that were on
the bottom of the hierarchy who really
lifted me up how does that make you feel
just very fortunate because it helps me
to keep my eyes on the prize if this was
just about me and just fighting for
myself I would definitely quit but
thinking back to all the people that
helped me it's just failure wasn't an
option Anthony this is one of the rare
interviews where actually I got tears in
my eyes after we ended you know when he
mentioned the people at the bottom a lot
of his former co-workers were
ex-convicts and the people like that
teacher will told him he needed to be in
special ed did not help him as much as
the folks at the bottom end of the
hierarchy as he says but he fought
through so much flattened and as you
pointed out I mean it was the folks at
the Bates trucking and trash removal
service who really encouraged him said
no go for it
he ended up being not only commencement
speaker he got a 4.0 average you know
there so there was obviously always
something there there were just so many
headwinds for him but I loved what he
said he said no one can promise you that
life will be fair but if you keep your
eyes on the prize everything will fall
into place
you need encouragement to that's key and
when a teacher tells you you're
handicapped you know it sure doesn't
help let
and Vlad he went to University of
Maryland that's where I went to so I'm
thinking you got water makes me sir